das ist wirklich ziemlich verrückt ist
scheint tatsächlich so dass es ihm bald
eine art internet das boot wide web gibt
demnach hätten die pflanzen schon
millionen jahre vor uns die
kommunikation über datenleitungen
erfunden immer mehr forschungsteams sind
mittlerweile von der theorie des
sogenannten wood wide web überzeugt das
internet des waldes ihr habt euch dieses
thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt
jetzt alle wichtigen facts wie schnell
ist das world wide web und wir werden
die kosten abgerechnet ja so wegfalls
scheint es wirklich zu geben das alles
und viel mehr jetzt bei pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen oder ein
ende er vater wieder zur whatsapp kommt
unzählige informationen gehen tag für
tag stunde für stunde ja sekunde für
sekunde durchs world wide web
alles was man davon wirklich sie sind
ein paar kabel server und der router in
der wohnung im wald liegt das netz unter
dem laub versteckt und mit seiner hilfe
kommunizieren bäume dazu der zellbiologe
frantisek baluska von der universität
bonn
bäume haben ihre eigenen probleme ihre
eigenen fähigkeiten mit problemen
umzugehen und sie kommunizieren auch
miteinander und lösen die probleme
miteinander und diese kommunikation der
pflanzen ist tatsächlich erst seit
einigen jahren als seriöse
wissenschaftliche fragestellung
anerkannt doch mitarbeiter steht fest
bäume kommunizieren nicht nur über duft
botschaften sondern auch über pilze
konkret handelt es sich um sogenannte
mykorrhiza weiße pilzfäden die
tatsächlich mit dem fun wurzelsystem der
bäume kontakt aufnehmen und botschaften
an andere pflanzen sträucher und bäume
übermitteln
genau wie beim world wide web werden
durch das world wide web also unzählige
nachrichten von baum zu baum gefunkt die
jeweils in einem netzwerk zusammen
gebunden sind experimente zeigen dass
sowohl wasser kohlenstoff und nährstoffe
zwischen den bäumen transportiert wird
und zwar ganz individuell abgestimmt auf
die verschiedenen bedürfnisse droht den
nachbar bäumen beispielsweise auch der
befall durch insekten kommuniziert dass
die kastanie an ihren nachbarn weiter
alles wird einigen studien zufolge
tatsächlich über sogenannte mutter bäume
gemanagt ähnlich wie beim film avatar im
übertragenen sinne sind pilze also die
glasfaserverbindung des waldes
forschungsteams nennen genau diese
verbindung mit web und das gesamte
ausmaß das kann man sich kaum vorstellen
denn die pilze dem wir im wald sehen das
sind nur die früchte die eigentlichen
pilze findet man unterirdisch und dort
sind sie riesengroß teilweise
quadratkilometern das größte lebewesen
der welt ist ein pilz es ist ein dunkle
hallimasch größe 1200 fußballfelder
gewicht 600 tonnen
zum verständnis wenn ein pilzsammler
also einen steinpilz findet und meint
einen pilz gefunden haben ist das in
etwa so als wenn man einen
einzigen ab befindet und sagt hey ich
hab einen apfelbaum gefunden der pilz
selbst ist also ein riesiges geflecht
die pilze sind nur die früchte oder
blüten wie bei blumen die dann die
sporen die samen verbreiten und wir
kennen das als internet user nur allzu
gut um das internet nutzen zu können
müssen wir zahlen und so geht es auch
den bäumen die wirklich hohe kosten
haben konkret stellen die pilze also die
möglichkeit der kommunikation heer also
das internet dafür bekommen sie nahrung
von den bäumen im klartext zuckerlösung
und das nicht zu knapp bis zu einem
drittel der gesamten photosynthese
produktion müssen die bäume an die pilze
zahlen eine art symbiose also die pilze
können sich nicht selbst ernähren sie
sind auf das angewiesen was ihnen andere
lebewesen zur verfügung stehen stellen
die bäume können erst durch die hilfe
der pilze kommunizieren
die wichtigste frage neben den kosten
ist natürlich die geschwindigkeit und
die ist den ball ziemlich gering
forschungsteams schätzen die
nachrichtenübertragung auf etwa einen
zentimeter pro sekunde und das ist für
die bäume im wald mehr als ausreichend
die wissenschaft tut sich mit diesem
thema also dem verhalten tatsächlich
noch etwas schwer es ist also noch nicht
wirkliche lehrmeinungen es gibt noch
unsicherheiten also ist die these noch
er im stadium der hypothese aber
mittlerweile gibt es publikationen die
eine kommunikation zwischen solchen baum
pilz netzwerken nachgewiesen haben
wenn man davon ausgeht dass pflanzen
kommunizieren sind viele fragen offen
verfügung pflanzen über ein
sozialverhalten
denn kommunikation ist schließt sich
eine soziale handlung sind bäume
sozialwesen dazu der biologe baluska ich
für meinen teil davon aus dass pflanzen
lebewesen sind wenn sie aber lebewesen
sind müssen sie auch ein sozialverhalten
haben als beispiel nennt der forscher in
einem interview junge bäume die in einem
ganz dichten wald wachsen normalerweise
müssten sie absterben da sie kaum licht
bekommen doch wenn sie mit den großen
bäumen drumherum verwandt sind bekommen
sie zucker über das pils netzwerk und
wachsen weiter baluska geht sogar noch
weiter
er ist sich sicher dass bäume auch ein
gedächtnis haben denn offensichtlich
nehmen sie die daten ihrer
umwelt nicht nur war sondern speichern
sie und stellen sich damit auf
veränderungen ein mehr als 20 parameter
die sich ständig verändern nehmen bäume
demnach aus der umwelt wahr und auf
dieser grundlage treffen sie dann
entscheidungen beispielsweise
entscheidet sich eine wurzel dann ob sie
nach links rechts nach oben oder nach
unten wächst all diese erkenntnisse die
es weiter zu erforschen gilt können uns
nur viele hinweise bezüglich unserem
umgang mit pflanzen geben wie
beispielsweise in der land und
forstwirtschaft beispielsweise folgt
daraus den schluss dass ältere
erwachsene bäume wichtig für das
wachstum der jüngeren sind also würde es
vorteile bringen wenn wir in der
forstwirtschaft die sogenannten mutter
bäume bestehen lassen außerdem sollten
wir unter rücksichtnahme auf
unterirdische netzwerke den vorgang des
pflügens bewusster einsetzen ja und wenn
ihr als erstes neues zu diesem thema zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir
vom neuesten video eben vorab garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion
von krieg zum mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge
machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach ihr
drauf kriegen und natürlich nicht das
abo mit der glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
kriegen pflanzen mit superkräften das
spannendes thema ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran